I'm a big fan of gremlins I know that  that's not necessarily a big monster but  it's a monster that was very important  to me growing up that's a really good  question I'd love to see him up against  a kind of a medieval dragon  a lot of the whole army of gremlins like  an old-school winged fire-breathing  dragon what you're looking at is a  monster from some pie guard error that  new dinosaur from Jurassic Park you know  the new one the breed the hog asaurus  rex yeah no but I think mine would be  probably super shredded from secret of  the ooze super shredder you remember  super shredder from Ninja Turtles it was  and he turned into like this super you  super shredded I just think he looks  cool yeah I think come here probably  beat him up I spent 30 years trying to  prove the truth monsters exist  you